sort of talk in terms of the the density
of equations unfortunately they're
somewhat unavoidable in the things that
I'm going to talk about and so this is
interesting right now we just went
through a whole lot of come on okay okay
so yes so this is joint work with Josh
and Monty and in fact you know Josh is
being very much the the main player in
this and in particular most of the
slides here I have to think Josh full so
you know what we're interested in is you
know we have a derived allele that's
arisen sometime in the past and then as
you know throughout time its frequency
in the population has gone up and down
until you know it's at some level at the
the present day and with you know we
sort of interested in various things
about the history of that allele you
know the time that it first arose in the
population and you know to what extent
it's been under selection and you know
to the things like the the dominance
coefficient if you don't quite remember
what those things are also described
those briefly in a little bit and the
sort of data that we have is you know at
a bunch of times in the past we have you
know samples of you know some
of chromosomes and you know and in those
samples will have some number of copies
of the derived allele and so that's you
know some kind of you know we can think
of it as an estimate of the the
frequency of the derived allele in the
population as at that time and of course
it may be the case as here that we're
sampling genetic material prior to the
the time that the allele arose and of
course at those times we're going to see
the derived allele that zero frequency
and of course at later times just by
chance we could also see it at zero
frequency as well okay and so I'm just
sort of let me remind you of the the
basic right Fisher story that you know
if you've been good boys and girls and
come to the boot camp you wouldn't i
wouldn't need to tell you this but then
i probably don't need to tell any of you
it either but you know we just have the
sort of basic right Fisher story where
we have two alleles and then this kind
of resembling mechanism that gets us
from one generation to the other and we
have you know kind of fair sampling if
we're in the neutral situation but if
there's some kind of selection going on
then they'll be favoritism of one allele
over the other and we're going to have
this sort of general diploid selection
model where you this homozygote you know
has fitness sort of 1 plus s you know
compared to the other homozygote and
then the the heterozygote has a fitness
of this
form here okay and you know if you just
go through a calculation of how the
expected allele frequency changes from
one generation to the next then you get
kind of a rather nasty looking
expression an even nastier looking
expression for the way that the variance
changes from one generation to the next
but you know up to you know kind of
smaller order terms it looks like this
and but you know we're going to think
that we're in the world where ends very
large and we gained a sort of pass to
the usual diffusion limit story that I
talked about in the boot camp where we
assume that the population size goes off
to infinity and our selection parameter
scales in such a way that two ns goes
off to a value alpha and then we get
this right Fisher stochastic
differential equation you know sort of a
drift term here that has all the details
of the selection embedded in it and then
the stochastic term or the diffusion
term that is just coming from the
resampling and is unaffected by anything
to do with the details of the the
selection okay and so one can also
suppose that population size is is very
and in such a way that you know on this
diffusion time scale so after you know
two NT generations the the population
size is of this form here so Rho T
represents the relative population size
with time measured in diffusion time
units then one also gets a stochastic
differential equation in in that
limiting regime and the the selection
looks exactly the same the drift term
looks exactly the same but the the
stochasticity is is changing and you
know so the larger the relative
population size is as we all know the
the effect of the stockist icity will be
you know diminished as it gets larger
okay so you know if we've got these sort
of samples of ancient DNA then you know
it's sort of if somehow we've been
actually given the the allyl frequency
path and well immediately we know what
on t0 is right because we just have to
see when the allyl starts having
positive frequency and the the two
selection parameters the the selection
strength and the dominance coefficient
those guys you know would be inferable
from the allele frequency path because
you know the likelihood of our data is
just going to be a bunch of binomials
well young well first start we could you
know if we knew the allele frequency
path we could do all sorts of things
doing fer I'll for an H but you know if
we also knew the allele frequency path
then you know the likelihood of the data
would be just binomials that wouldn't
depend on alpha H right or t0 right
they'd be just things to do with the
population frequencies at the time that
we sampled however because we don't
actually observe that likelihood
frequency path and so
if we want you know the likelihood of
the data just given these scalar
parameters alpha H and T 0 the things
that we want to win infer then computing
the likelihood is hard because we've
sort of got to integrate out the whole
allele frequency path this kind of
infinite dimensional type object and
doing that is morally equivalent to
solving a PDE that doesn't have some
nice kind of closed form solution and
I'm you know despite that there's been
sort of various attempts at doing this
kind of inference you know the the
earliest paper i think you know souls
that the the PDE numerically this paper
here of which which money and I were
work oo authors is you know doing a
particular approximation to the PDE
using birth and death processes person
death type Markov chains and then I
think the most recent paper in this area
by matias tomo command and others you
know using orthogonal polynomial ideas
to approximate you know effect
essentially the the solutions of the the
PDE that come up from doing this this
integrating out the path type story okay
well because of this fact that the the
likelihood of the data given the the
allele frequency path is you know
something that's easy to compute a sort
of a natural idea is to just take this
unknown frequency path as you know just
yet another parameter that you you have
to estimate now that sort of seems okay
well that's sort of a nice idea because
now you've got easy likelihoods but of
course you know this'll only work if you
got a prior that makes sense right if
your prior on the pie
is you know that it's just a straight
line with an unknown slope well you know
that's got no kind of connection with
you know the Alpha and the H that you're
interested in estimating so you know
this approach is really only going to
tell you something if you know you work
with the right prior and the prior
should be such that you know under that
prior the conditional distribution of
the allele frequency path given alpha
action t0 and you know that you're
seeing something that's an allyl that's
segregating at the present is that you
know it should be what it is under our
right Fisher stochastic differential
equation model okay so you know this is
a promising idea as a way of you know
getting alpha H and T 0 using
essentially off the shelf ideas for for
doing bayesian inference using mcmc type
ideas but it also carries with it a
little bit of a bonus because it gives
you some kind of an imputation of what
the the allele frequency path was and
that's something that we might be
interested in you know just for its own
sake okay and so as I sort of already
intimated the the obvious way to
approach this is if we're going to be
bayesian zyzz to get you know a
posterior using some sort of mcmc idea
like metropolis hastings and you know
when we sort of do metropolis Hastings
we're just because we're usually working
with things like scalar parameters or
you know vector valued parameters you
know without even really thinking about
it you know we're always working with
likelihoods right so we're assuming that
you know or or densities
another way of saying it right so
there's always some reference measure in
the background such that the probability
measures that we're working with have
densities against those measures
rightness for vector valued things is
usually just you know lebesgue measure
on whatever dimensional Euclidean space
where we're working with but here you
know the path is this kind of infinite
dimensional object and so we need to be
working with some probability measure on
the the space of possible oil frequency
paths where you know we have reference
measures that are useful for for doing
the kind of ratios in MC MC yeah so I
don't see that the dimension of million
although there's a fun part the only
Union care about time super short
serving right but we need the stuff the
whole thing is if we only care about
those things than that integrating the
PDE right well we don't we don't want to
do that that's the whole point we're
trying to avoid doing that yeah I mean
mathematically that's true the you know
the likelihood just involves exactly
those things and then you have to worry
about you know what's the probability as
Devils right and that's something that's
nasty whereas this this procedure
actually integrate does solves the PDE
for you without you noticing that it's
happening right that's what's what's
going on but this is doing if you like
these infinite dimensional so you know
expectations of these functionals on an
infinite-dimensional space that you
could solve the PDE to get but we don't
want to do that and so it just
automatically mcmc automatically
computes the expectations of these fun
forums times care about but we should
yeah but you need to have you need that
sort of write down likelihood that's
right and that's involved so grumpy do
you continuous time right so you know we
were avoiding doing that right I'll of
pdes but you know it's sort of nice when
you know you don't actually have to you
know think too much right okay so what
do we get you know just a little bit of
stochastic analysis so let's just use
this notation here for you know the
distribution of a Brownian motion that's
going to start at some time T star in
position X and now suppose we've got a
stochastic differential equation that
looks like this the stochastic term you
know we just have a Brownian motion
without any coefficients out the front
of it and then we've just got this time
in space dependent drift term okay and
this classical theorem of hasanoff says
that you know if we look at the the law
of paths that satisfy this sde then that
probability measure is absolutely
continuous with respect to the whoops
absolutely continuous with respect to
the distribution of the the Brownian
motion with this very nice explicit
right on macadam derivative and this is
not all the way out of time infinity
this is you know if we just look at
paths that are over some finite interval
from time T star up the tea that you
know this is the density of this
probability measure here with respect to
this reference probability measure so
we've got these nice explicit densities
okay but you know there seems to be a
fly in the ointment right
the right Fisher sde doesn't look like
the sort of guy that ghassan off applies
to write to which kasanoff applies right
that you know ghassan off is all about
guys that are just you know Brownian
motion plus a adrift and here we've got
something a little bit complicated out
the front of the Brownian motion so
we'll have to do a little bit of
pre-processing to beat things into shape
where the Sun off will apply and that's
going to be just via a time and space
transformation and so the the time scale
is sort of something fairly obvious you
know we just going to you know go to
this new time scale here right remember
this is the the relative population size
and you know no surprises this is what
happens to the right Fisher diffusion
when we sort of stretching squeeze time
using this transformation that you know
we get a diffusion term that looks like
just the the right Fisher guy with
constant population size but then the
stuff that's going on with the drift
term that's encompass in the selection
you know that gets messed around a
little and the F inverse there are just
should stress is not one over but the
you know the functional inverse of this
monotone function okay so the the space
transform arm is somewhat cleverer but
you know fortunately somebody extremely
clever no Fisher had already figured it
out for us and so if you just um
transform the space variable so the you
know use space i mean the frequency you
know the the frequency variable then
they're using just it owes lemma you get
this rather complicated looking ste here
with you know sort of rather nasty
looking drift term but the good thing is
that we just have a nice unadorned
Brownian motion for the stochastic term
and so I'm your son off scheme to apply
right so so theoretically that's great
but we sort of had this difficulty that
this transformed guys space and time
transformed guy lives on sort of 0 pi
and of course it can go on 20 or PI and
that corresponds to to loss of fixation
whereas our reference probability
measure is something about Brownian
motion which is just a process that
freely windows over all of the reels and
so what's going on here the sort of the
consequence of this is that this drift
term here yeah I'm sure you see it
automatically right it blows up when the
variable here goes to either 0 or PI
right you remember right cut is you know
cause over sine and sine of 0 and sign
of pyre both equal to 0 so bad things
happen as you approach the the boundary
and so that's going to create a bit of a
problem with densities blowing up when
we want to infer alia lage so we need to
have a reference measure that's
something other than the the
distribution of Brownian motion and that
sort of more tuned to the the problem
that we're working with yep
the tags here you don't know when the
points per sample and you know it's
deterministic right because it's what
it's been moved around by the time
change yeah but the time changes a
deterministic one it's just using the
population size 1 over Rho is
deterministic we're not assuming those
know yeah we're assuming that rose know
right yeah it's not something that we're
in furry yeah okay and so you know now
you know suppose that we've got two of
these found sdes that your sign-off
applies to then we know that they've
both got their laws both have densities
with respect to the the lure of the
appropriate Brownian motion and so you
know if you're just willing to sort of
accept this kind of you know heuristic
little argument here which you can
actually make rigorous you get that the
lure of the the first guy has a density
with respect to the law of the the
second guy which is just you know a
ratio of gusano fee type densities ok so
again something that's really you know
sort of nice and concrete and easy to
work with ok so now you know we saw that
you know our time and space transformed
right Fisher by and we'll write this for
its distribution you know her salt the
an sde that just had an unadorned
Brownian part and disappearing in the
drift ok and i said this blows up as
white all goes to 0 and this is exactly
how it does blow up as white or goes to
0 and so when seeking a
better reference measure than Brownian
motion it might be a good idea to apply
this kind of story here where the the
sde that's giving rise to the the new
reference measure the thing that we're
going to put on the bottom here to get
our density is something that where the
drift terms have the same type of
singularity as white or is going down to
zero right because if we do that then
we're not going to have densities going
off to infinity and creating problems in
our mcmc algorithm okay and so that sort
of suggests that our new reference
measure should be something that where
the coefficient in the drift term has
this kind of singularity as the the
frequency variable goes down to zero and
of course well you know we could just
take q to be equal to P but the whole
point is that we you know don't know how
to the sample from things related to pee
easily and so it'd be better to have not
necessary for implementing something
like metropolis Hastings to have
something that we can sample from quite
easily so that we can you know do the
whole story with proposals etc in
Metropolis Hastings okay so another
little bit of stochastic analysis is you
know let's just sort of note something
that you know if I've got a dimensional
on standard Brownian motion then because
of the radial symmetry of this guy if I
just take the radial part of it that'll
be a Markov process in its own right
normally when you take a function of a
Markov process you don't get something
that's Markov here you do because
the radial symmetry and the resulting
Markov process the resulting diffusions
called a vessel process of dimension D
and usually written that way and again
if you apply it owes lemma you see that
this guy satisfies a nice little
stochastic differential equation and
this stochastic differential equation
makes sense for all values of the
parameter D that a non-negative whether
or not DS an integer right because this
definition here depends on D being an
integer but this SD makes sense no
matter what non-negative number D is and
so this such a process will call the D
dimensional Bessel process and you know
Josh did some some nice simulation so
here's sort of the case D equals to
where we've got a you know a
two-dimensional Brownian path and then
when we look at the radial part we get a
nice curve that looks like this right
which starts at zero and then doesn't go
back to zero because you know as we know
Brownian motion will get arbitrarily
close to zero at times in the future but
never return exactly 20 okay so let's
sort of remember that when the frequency
variable is small the the drift of our
time and space transform right Fisher
diffusion looks like this and the the
zero dimensional Bessel diffusion
satisfied an sde like that and so we see
that the singularities are matching up
exactly in the way we want right so it
looks like the the distribution of the
zero dimensional vessel process is a
good candidate for a reference measure
but remember we need a reference measure
that that's sort of something that we
can sample from
and actually before I get to that let me
just sort of mention one other point
which is that this consequence of
ghassan off was that you know if we've
got you know our you know if we had our
right Fisher guys space-time transform
right Fisher guy and this was our own
ZrO dimensional Bessel guy then the the
density of this guy with respect to that
is going to be given by this ratio of
things from gas on off and so to compute
this numerically it seems as though
you've got to do stochastic quadrature
right you've got to numerically evaluate
an ito integral and you know people know
that that's kind of not a nice thing to
do numerically but there's you know a
very nice observation that's being
exploited quite extensively in the group
around gareth roberts oh that Warwick
where you know they figured out that
just essentially by a clever integration
by parts type idea you can convert on
these stochastic integrals in do
expressions that just involve you know
ordinary well riemann integrals okay and
so that's a kind of means that these
things aren't as nasty numerically as
you might think they are okay but we
still got a you know another thing to
address which is you know our space and
time transformed right Fisher diffusion
you know if we should started you know
exactly at zero it's you know being to
stay there so we'll Bessel zero it
doesn't get away from from zero zeros a
an absorbing boundary point and so you
know because what's happening is that
we've seen a an allyl that has escaped
from zero its kind of done on something
exceptional it's been lucky enough to
you know be brought into being by a
mutation in some individual and then
make it to macroscopic frequency in the
population and so you know our prior
will need to take that into account and
put you know its mass on paths that
actually start at zero at some time in
the past but then managed to escape from
there and so you know we so I know we're
piling on the stochastic analysis here
but you know we need a sort of another
idea from stochastic analysis which is
this notion of an entrance law so our
right Fisher guy you know because of the
you know messing up the space and time
scale you know it's a Markov process but
it's time in homogeneous it's you know
the the dynamics of what you do and
depend on not just where you are but
what the time is and so you know this is
you know the the the density against
lebesgue from going from position X at
time s to position Y at time T and then
an entrance law is you know sort of a
way of getting the things started from a
some time T star and so it's a way of
getting the things started such that you
know after time T star it just evolves
according to these transition dynamics
and that's what this equation here says
right that if I start a t-star and then
you know I somehow get the time s and
position X and then let it evolve to
time T then
it's just the same as you know my recipe
for where I should be at time T starting
from T star right and so the the bezels
ero guy has a very nice entrance law you
can write down explicitly what the the
transition density function is for the
Bessel zero process it's something that
involves surprise surprise Bessel
functions that's works cool but the
Bessel zero process and you know in some
nice 19th century mathematics and if you
just use the the asymptotic behavior of
the the Bessel function as the argument
goes to zero you end up seeing that this
object here is an entrance law for the
entrance time T star right so this is a
way of getting our process away from
zero and then the you know letting it
evolve like that like the vessel zero
guy thereafter okay so now the thing
about this is that the entrance law
doesn't define a probability measure on
past space that in it defines a measure
with you know infinite total mass
because you know what we have to do is
you know to get the thing away from 0
well you know if we've got paths away
from 0 you know starting at zero they
really want to go you know stay at zero
right so there's this sort of thing that
we have to you know put more and more
mass at you know tiny little paths that
just wink into existence and then wink
out of existence straight away but we
can build this you know infinite measure
on oops on path space that you know
as its finite dimensional distributions
given by the recipe that you'd think
that you know somehow magically we get
to position X 1 at time s one that's
bigger than the time that everything
starts and then after that the the
dynamics are just the the Bessel zero
dynamics okay now we can do exactly the
same thing with right Fisher we can
force right Fisher to get away from zero
by you know remembering this is the the
distribution of right Fisher that starts
at position X at time T star and has of
course the the selection and dominance
parameters alpha H and then this is our
new candidate for the reference measure
the the Bessel zero guy and we always
have this as the density of the the
right Fisher against the Bessel zero guy
it's always of this form and so remember
this now is our reference guide the
Bessel zero that's you know forced to
get away from zero and then we just you
know whack in you know the obvious
density that you know is you know from
here the the correct one to use because
you know we always had this density no
matter what the starting point x is and
you know this defines now a dynamic for
the right Fisher process that's getting
it away from zero and then evolving
thereafter as it should okay now the way
I sort of define things there this
object is you know an infinite measure
on past space
that you know is defined on paths that
you know just our index from time T star
onwards but of course we can think of
that as a measure on pars indexed by the
whole of the the real line by just
setting the paths to be 0 up to this you
know time T star when the paths forced
to get away from 0 and so now you know
we've sort of gone through a lot of you
know kind of convolutions but we're sort
of finally at the point of defining what
our prior should be on the allele
frequency path it's going to be you know
an improper prior okay so you know when
I say conditional you know the scalar
parameters we're just going to you know
if we sort of just for the moment
condition on them then the part of the
prior that describes the the time and
space transformed our lil frequency path
is just going to be this guy here right
so this is saying you know we're forcing
ourselves to get away from 0 at this
time here right now t0 is in you know
calendar time the the time that the a
lil arose but after we've done the time
change you know this is the the time
that's the the time and space rescaled
right Fisher is actually leaving 0 and
you know because we have to use the
dynamics that have the appropriate
selection and dominance parameters yeah
you're actually forcing it to get away
from 0 at T 0 or just in some time
well it just yet it's at 0 at T at T 0 0
ft s are on there straight away it after
that it leaves right so you're forcing
it to do something kind of lewd and
unnatural but you know that's why it has
to be a you know a an infinite measure
right but I mean also just you'd expect
that okay you saw it at 0 at T 0 it was
actually 0 for some time after that and
then some time before the next but g0 is
by definition the time that is away from
zero yes it's not the s that's probably
notation that we should change it t0 is
the real age whereas the t1 t2 there the
sample times I'm amazed that you mighty
star was just I'm today because f p0 is
I didn't want to use t0 because you know
the thing that I'm going to plug in here
is ft 0 so you know it's this is the
time when everything gets going right
and so the the time that everything gets
going for the the actual allele
frequency path is 20 but after we've
done the transformation the time that
everything gets going for the
transformed path is ft 0 yeah that's
quite a lot of stuff yeah right would
you also want to condition on that right
so that's yeah exactly a good point that
you know ideally one would like to have
that what we were taking is not the
right Fisher measure sort of done like
this but in fact right Fisher that is
you know in a sense conditioned to start
at zero and be between 0 and 1 you know
at the present day right
similarly as the reference measure to
use something like Bessel 0 that's
conditioned to do the same thing ok the
problem with that is that the you know
there's sort of your back to sort of
needing to solve the PDE to get the the
kind of denominators in that
conditioning right you need to know you
know what's essentially the probability
that you know this you know a
probability distribution of kind of
where you are the the end and so this
yeah i was going to some say this but
you kind of you know force me to to say
it now is you know just you know doesn't
completely catch that thing it's going
to be something's distribution lee very
close to that because you know in a
sense what we're doing is conditioning
the the right Fisher to get away from 0
right I mean that doesn't make sense in
terms of giving you a probability
measure it gives you something that's
one of these infinite measures write
this this infinite measure really is
right Fisher condition to get away from
zero for you know some positive time and
you know who and so the conditionings
slightly different to what you'd want
but the fact that we're then you know
got data that's telling us that the the
allele frequency is strictly positive at
all you know various sample times is
kind of going to be throwing away the
the paths that correspond to you know
the process just winking into existence
and then winking out so the the
conditioning that we really want to have
there is to some extent you know at a
sort of you know forced to happen by you
know it's using using the data to tell
us that you know you know we you know
even though you know the the prior puts
mass on paths that you know come into
existence and then die you know the data
tells us that you know they they can't
be ones that are relevant to our problem
okay and so then of course we've got to
have five minutes run yet so then we
better have you know sort of priors on
the selection coefficient and the
dominance coefficient and you know just
take whatever you your favorite kind of
prior is for um for scalars and then I
we also need a prior on the early age
and there's good reasons for using the
improper prior that has the its density
you know against lebesgue measure is
just being the relative population size
at time T so you know in times when the
population size is greater you know
there's you're more likely to be seeing
the the allele arise there and then you
know just multiply all your your priors
together to get you know a marginal
prior on these three scalar parameters
and then of course on the previous slide
we described what the the the
conditional prior is on the path given
the scale of parameters and so we've
given a complete specification of the
the full prior on the the time that the
alil arose the the selection and
dominance coefficients and the allele
frequency path okay and so you know
is sort of then how you're going to
implement sort of Metropolis Hastings
and you know the thing is that we've got
to have some you know proposal mechanism
for getting ourselves around path space
right some way of you know taking a path
and you know proposing a new path and
you know what we've got to do is you
know how are you going to sort of
proposed a new path well you know you
just pick a little interval and then the
piece of path between those two time
points you're just going to update it
and you gain to the proposal is going to
be you know drawn according to the
distribution of a so-called vessel
breach right so bessel zero process
that's conditioned to you know start at
the beginning of the interval you know
where the previous part bit of path
started end at the end of that interval
at the place where the the previous path
better path started and then you know
follow the the bessel zero dynamics in
between that and this is sort of easy to
simulate one of these bridges so easy to
do a proposal in terms of a another nice
little bit of stochastic analysis which
looking at nikko I don't have time for
it's a sort of a fascinating but non
obvious fact that bridges for a vessel 0
process which is this sort of rather
mysterious thing right because you know
the vessels with positive integer
dimensions had something to do with
Brownian motions radial parts of
Brownian motions whereas this zero
dimensional guy what's it well bridges
of this guy are the same as bridges of a
vessel for process so you
and simulate these things just by
simulating bridges of Bessel fours and
you know in order to do that you've got
to do a little bit of stuff worrying
about you know radial parts of Brownian
motion and things like that and say
you've got to do things with fun me
suspicious tributions and things but
it's not that hard to do and so that's
you know a bit of path in the middle how
do we update it well the updates of the
allyl age similar you know we do
something you know we want to update
from here to here for the early age well
we just got to build a vessel zero
bridge from here to here which is the
same as a vessel for bridge and you know
the proposal ratio needs to account for
the appropriate densities of the pubs
that do this thing and similarly the the
you know the final bit of path the the
updating of that is just a similar type
of idea and you know here's just a
picture of you know what an update looks
like in the middle of the path at the
start of the path and at the end of the
path just like they described them the
three previous slides and so let's just
look at a particular example for the
Aesop locus in in horses so you know the
the data is these one two three four
five six dots and you know what we have
here is that the the black line is the
the median of the the posterior
distribution at each point in time of
the the allele frequency path the the
red guys are the upper and lower
quartiles and
so the the green guy green guys you know
they're the 95th percentile and 5th
percentile and so then you know here's
the posterior of the allyl age right
obviously you know the earlier age is
going to be concentrated at times prior
to when you started seeing positive
frequency in your samples but it tails
off you know really quickly and you know
here's the the the prior for the Alpha
parameter and the its posterior marginal
posterior and it's hard to see the the
dotted guy is the prior for the the
dominance parameter and the solid guy is
the the posterior and you know here's
the joint posterior for the the two
parameters dealing with selection so you
see that it's looking like the the
dominance parameter is is positive and
also you know the Alpha the selection
parameter is positive and you know in
fact the the most likely values of those
parameters are the following so you're
in this over dominance situation and so
that leads to you know the these
posterior distributions on the
trajectories you know quickly rising and
then kind of leveling out right at some
measures with that quite well and so
just some acknowledgment oops sorry unto
you know people that you know
particularly Josh's just talked to down
in
Valley life sciences and just some of
the the papers that got mentioned there
and sort of what they're about and just
some of this stuff about right Fisher
bridges is a paper with Josh Bob
Griffiths and myself and Josh also has a
really nice paper on thinking about
right Fisher in the world of you know
sort of path integrals you know sort of
a little you know a nice sort of variant
on the usual kind of stochastic calculus
kind of way of thinking about things
okay thanks very much yes sorry yeah
right i mean that's of course the you
know exactly the sort of issue right and
you know that's sort of all of these
things of you know assume that you're
dealing with a pen mythic population and
ya know I you must have some story for
why this doesn't change for us now I
mean it's just a well of course you know
one would you know then need to you know
start talking about you know of course
what goes into here is just the usual
sort of boilerplate about well effective
population sizes and right Fisher still
works as long as you put in n sub e
instead of then you know etc etc right
so that's you know and of course there
are rigorous results that established
that but it is a leap of faith for sure
and horses can run
so it's too long we can take it all
right later but at the most basic level
a lot of your stuff reminds me of the
stuff that idea Anthony Edwards used to
do with mind immunity drifts on surface
of the sphere right but a lot of that
but it never solved the problem of what
your dog did when you got to the edges
of the authors so I wondered how much of
your machinery is really because you're
worried about this zero frequency what
happens at the bandwidth that's I mean
that requires yeah a lot of extra yeah
kind of worrying to sort of do that to
handle this that you're you know you're
not just dealing with you know right
Fisher you're dealing with right Fisher
conditioned on an event of zero
probability and so you know this thing's
the condition guy you know magically
gets away from zero but from there on
it's I'm going to have a distribution
that's absolutely continuous with
respect to that of you know the
unconditioned right Fisher so and the
other thing was that oh yeah we're doing
promise with continuous time Markov
chain time growing cnc and Vladimir
minun who's done a lot of that work has
got some really nice results where you
can do NC NC by augmenting the process
so then you have a process that you can
salt off wrong well that's that's what
we did here I mean putting the path in
is exactly that augmentation idea right
that we're much more complicated under
the sorts of augmentation seems to be
using yeah yeah but this is the sort of
thing that you know people in the signal
processing community and stuff like that
when they talk about our data
augmentation it's you know essentially
that you know instead of thinking that
you've just sampled signal which I see
what is see but in order to sample from
that continuous proneness he's
augmenting that process so it's not just
a dawat an augmentation by putting in a
path right it's by putting in additional
events into that underlying continuous
prior if you want to try and sample from
okay and which enables you to sample
from the nominees process
but my dreams I don't know if that has
yeah that might actually be irrelevant
yeah that's always worth let's hope that
we saw over to base people